this album to me is
like i listened to the whole album three
times straight through i feel like
probably like
i was expecting a little bit more of a
vulnerable album from you even though
there's some vulnerable moments
based on just the name of the project
yeah
it's like you said there's there's
vulnerability
in the album but i'm having a lot of fun
making the music and i think you can
hear it in the records and a lot of the
songs are
inspired by all the concerts i've been
doing over the last year
and so
i think i couldn't hide the fact that
i'm enjoying my life
and um
you know that's not a reason to shy away
from vulnerability i found my moments
for it but i had a lot of fun making
this music and
i say that genuinely because in the past
i think i've let
people's opinion affect my own
perception of my music you know i've let
how people view it i can go listen and
it can kind of reshape how i hear my own
stuff and i'm like
well it could be better
but
i think this time around like
you know maybe the whole world isn't on
the same wavelength as me in terms of
maybe they can't relate well that's how
i'm feeling by the way i mean i would
say the whole world might be because
first class i think is like what came
out was number one first week so like
point being
there's been nothing that's been said
that has been able to convince me that
this music isn't special this music is
incredibly special and i think it's
gonna age
timelessly and that's something i'm
really proud of because like i said i've
been able to be convinced in the past
i've been able to people been able to
make me doubt myself but this time
around like
i feel really good about the album like
it's my best body of work and i'm gonna
continue to grow but i'm i really love
it